stéphane augé chef du service de
réanimation pédiatrique à l'hôpital
robert debré membres du collectif inter
hôpitaux bonsoir ses fans dauger merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
était une journée en tout cas forte en
symbole est importante pour le personnel
hospitalier vous étiez présent la
conférence de presse comment ça s'est
passé
bon sang on avait écouté la conférence
de presse s'est plutôt bien passé nous
avons obtenu l'horaire comme nous avons
l'habitude de le faire
nous avons pu exposer l'ensemble des
problèmes de l'hôpital public et faire
témoigner des collègues d'hôpitaux
universitaires d'hôpitaux universitaires
c'est une représentante des usagers qui
a parlé en premier et qui a témoigné des
difficultés de l'hôpital public depuis
plusieurs années nous avons aussi
précisé quelles étaient les conséquences
de cette démission collective de plus de
100 buts maintenant mille trois cents
chefs de service et nous avons ensuite
répondu aux questions à la presse nous
étions très heureux d'avoir pu faire
cette conférence de presse et qui s'est
déroulé comme nous l'avions prévu
'l'annonce votre annonce aujourd'hui et
elle eu l'effet escompté
écoutez à ma connaissance non pour
l'instant je ne crois pas qu'on ait eu
un contact avec le ministère de la santé
où le premier nice on attend d'en savoir
plus je viens d'apprendre il ya quelques
minutes que de nouveaux hôpitaux se
proposait de plusieurs chefs de service
d'autres hôpitaux donc d'autres chu qui
jusque là n'avait pas signé était prêt à
signer on doit être en contact avec eux
demain je pense que la pression continue
à monter j'espère que le ministère de la
santé va nous répondre rapidement et
qu'on va pouvoir sa table s'asseoir
autour d'une table de négociation pour
avancer très clairement pour construire
l'hôpital de demain vous le rappelle à
vous avez présenté votre démission
collective de vos responsabilités
administratives est ce que tous autant
que vous êtes vous êtes capable d'aller
jusqu'au bout de cette démission
réellement bien écoutez je pense que oui
mesdames parce que nous avions d'abord
pris des précautions nous réfléchissons
à cette deuxième étape qui est venue
après la rétention du collage si vous
vous souvenez bien nous avions
initialement arrêtées transmettre à
l'assurance maladie
le couple l'hospitalisation des patients
malgré cela nous n'avons pas été
entendus donc nous avions prévu de sa
démission nous avions
depuis longtemps le nombre de
démissionnaires a augmenté très
clairement sur les dernières semaines
nous avons expliqué à chacun de nos
collègues de bien réfléchir d'en parler
avec leurs équipes d'en parler avec
leurs futurs d'en parler avec l'ensemble
des collègues avec qui travaille
d'habitude pour être bien sûr des
conséquences de cet acte et nous avons
même relancé chacun d'entre eux pour
être certain qu'ils iraient jusqu'au
bout
à ma connaissance une seule personne a
dit que ça lui semblait compliqué a
préféré se retirer de la liste
ce pourquoi il a été aussi créer une
liste de soutien aux démissionnaires qui
ce matin avait à peu près 5000
signatures de personnes qui ne sont pas
chef de service mais qui soutiennent
notre geste
donc je pense très sincèrement que
l'ensemble des signataires lancé en
conscience après avoir bien réfléchi et
iront jusqu'au bout et je vous dis
encore avant que nous clôturerons cette
liste pour la donner à la presse il ya à
peu près 48 72 heures et il y avait
encore à peu près 70 à 80 signatures de
chef de service de tous les hôpitaux
publics français qui signe et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est à 1352 gens qui
sont très motivés oui on rappelle
évidemment pour doter les spectateurs
qui n'auraient pas suivi qui a bien plan
un énième plan a lancé le 20 novembre en
quoi celui-ci
rappelez-nous n'était encore pas
suffisant pour vous que demandez vous
concrètement aujourd'hui nos
revendications n'ont pas changé madame
d'abord nous sommes tout à fait
conscients de l'effort qui a été fait le
typiquement le rachat d'un tiers de la
dette des hôpitaux dont on aimerait
savoir exactement pourquoi ils se sont
endettés entre autres dans les marchés
financiers avec des risques majeurs mais
cette question est réglée maintenant que
le gouvernement rachète et que l'état
rachète un tiers de la dette des
hôpitaux c'est quelque chose d'important
il n'empêche que nos principales
revendications sont les suivantes et
vous les connaissez nous les
donnons au ministre de la santé depuis
déjà de nombreux mois
premièrement une augmentation de l'ondam
est du financement de la sécurité
sociale à 4,3 pour cent par rapport à
l'année précédente et pas 2,3 comme ça a
été conseillé par le gouvernement sinon
d'emblée les hôpitaux se remettront à
être endetté dès les premiers mois de
l'année la réouverture de vie en aval
des urgences et en aval des soins aigus
si vous notez bien ça n'a jamais été
proposé par le gouvernement et la
revalorisation salariale des tout petits
salaires de la fonction publique
hospitalière
que ce soit les soignants les aides
soignantes des infirmières que sur les
techniciens les ouvriers les jeunes
médecins qui s'installent pour que les
médecins et paramédicaux l'ensemble des
personnels techniques et administratifs
ne faut pas les oublier
soit avec nous et reste dans l'hôpital
public pour continuer à construire
l'hôpital de demain
à ce jour aucune de ses revendications
avaient été satisfaites on nous a
proposé des primes on nous a proposé
pour certains pas pour d'autres dans
certaines villes pas pour d'autres ce
n'est pas une mesure globale pour
l'hôpital public et non nous ne sommes
pas satisfaits aujourd'hui clairement ce
n'est pas un problème de système qu'il
faut revoir de fond en comble et arrêté
peut-être de colmater les brèches alors
nous nous sommes donc de fond en comble
je ne sais pas en tous les cas le
constat est que nous étions reconnus par
les instances internationales comme le
premier système de santé public en 2000
dans le monde et que nous sommes tombés
au 6e au 7e rang quelques années il ya
sans doute des choses à changer les
maladies ont évolué les la population
vieillit des pathologies chroniques sont
importantes moi je suis pédiatre
réanimateur
là aussi la pédiatrie a changé je pense
que nous sommes dans un métier comme
plein d'autres mais nous en sommes
1 dans lequel nous absorbons les
changements il nous sommes capables de
beaucoup de souplesse et flexibilité à
nous adapter
il n'empêche qu'il faut changer
effectivement le paradigme ce n'est plus
soigné au moindre coup quoi qu'il arrive
c'est soigné au juste coût et partir des
besoins de la population et certainement
pas donne
une volonté d'économies à tout crin il
faut effectivement changer le système
pour qu'on regarde exactement ce dont
les gens ont besoin est là nous serons
prêts et c'est la motivation de
l'ensemble des soignants de tous les
personnels de l'hôpital public a avancé
très clairement s'il le faut dans une
nouvelle version de l'hôpital public
mais partant des besoins de la
population et pas l'inversé savard et
être des mesures parfaitement dans son
ce que n'importe qui peut comprendre ce
que vous êtes en train de d'évoquer la
que vous répond la ministre quand vous
lui parlez comme ça clairement je crois
qu'on lui parle enfin moi je m'étais
avec elle que pour une réunion suite aux
difficultés des bronchiolites et de
l'épidémie hivernale de la réanimation
pédiatrique en ile-de-france qui est un
problème bien limité par rapport à
d'autres mais qui est un très bon témoin
de la gravité de la situation
je pense que les messages ont été très
clair depuis longtemps vous le savez
sans doute les gériatres on le dit à
chaque fois les psychiatres depuis
longtemps les urgentistes depuis
quasiment bientôt un an
et puis l'ensemble de l'hôpital public
maintenant pour l'instant nous n'avons
pas des réponses à la hauteur 1
madame la ministre nous explique que son
plan est très bon et nous fait de la
communication de très bon niveau pour
nous expliquer que c'est le meilleur
soit nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec ça
nous voulons avancer et je pense que ce
geste qui nous a coûté beaucoup dont on
connaît l'importance démontre très bien
qu'il faut qu'on passe à autre chose on
veut s'asseoir il faut des gestes forts
sur nos principales revendications et
nous viendrons à la table pour
travailler sur la gouvernance du nouvel
hôpital avec les usages et les
paramédicaux l'ensemble des soignants
nous sommes prêts à ça nous avons envie
d'avancer il n'y a aucun doute là dessus
merci stéphane augé chef de service de
réanimation pédiatrique à l'hôpital
robert debré d'avoir pris le temps de
nous répondre en direct sur rt france
merci à vous